J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Hello tout le monde, ça fait déjà presque neuf mois que Vladimir Poutine a relancé son assaut contre l'Ukraine et je souhaitais depuis longtemps réaliser un épisode qui explique
les relations particulières entre l'Europe et la Russie et particulièrement donc avec le Kremlin.
C'est aujourd'hui chose faite puisque je reçois un ancien journaliste qui a écrit un livre au sujet des relations entre l'Occident et Vladimir Poutine.
On parle de géopolitique, mais aussi de politique française. D'ailleurs, mon invité a tellement parlé d'Emmanuel Macron que j'ai dû couper un petit peu par-ci, par-là.
Et je précise aussi que l'interview a été enregistrée avant les événements du quinze novembre deux mille vingt-deux, quand deux missiles se sont écrasés en Pologne et ont fait deux victimes.
À l'heure où je vous parle, Zelensky maintient que les missiles étaient russes, la Maison Blanche affirme qu'ils étaient ukrainiens.
Bref, on n'a évidemment pas abordé ça. C'est parti pour Septante Minutes Avec Nicolas Hénin. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Nicolas Hénin. Bonjour Nicolas.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes spécialiste du Moyen-Orient. Vous avez notamment couvert la guerre en Irak et les printemps arabes. Vous avez également écrit La France russe : enquête sur le réseau de Poutine en deux mille seize chez Fayard.
C'est le sujet dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui. Et vous n'êtes aujourd'hui plus journaliste puisque vous travaillez principalement sur la lutte contre la désinformation et la prévention de la radicalisation. Un large CV.
Sacré programme.
J'ai oublié de préciser, mais donc vous êtes français et je le disais, votre spécialité première, ça a plutôt été lié historiquement au Moyen-Orient.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à vous pencher sur la Russie et plus particulièrement sur les actions du Kremlin en France ?
Un accident de promotion de mon premier livre.
Mais c'est formidable.
Jihad Academy, écrit rapidement après mon retour de Syrie. Dans ma couverture des printemps arabes, j'ai couvert la Syrie.
En Syrie, j'ai été pris en otage par Daesh pendant près d'un an.
Et à mon retour, j'ai assez rapidement arrêté le journalisme, mais je me suis lancé dans une forme de plaidoyer, parce qu'il y avait des choses auxquelles j'avais assisté,
une expérience que j'avais entre l'Irak et la Syrie, qui était à mon avis essentielle pour rappeler comment la situation syrienne avait pu déraper à ce point.
Et donc, je me retrouve invité dans plusieurs médias, de façon plus ou moins heureuse. Il y a des émissions que j'ai adoré faire et d'autres que j'ai détestées, panne d'eau en clair sur la fréquence.
Et je me suis retrouvé invité pour une conférence signature dans une librairie. En soi, un truc complètement anodin.
Sauf que je découvre que c'est une librairie qui a un affichage, une vitrine au propre et au figuré, j'ai envie de dire tiers-mondiste.
Tiers-mondiste ?
Ouais.
C'est-à-dire ?
Donc, c'est-à-dire, qui affiche son soutien aux grandes figures panafricaines comme à Juliana Singe. Un truc comme ça.
En soi, pourquoi pas ? Enfin, je veux dire, il faut parler à tout le monde et
Et y a des causes, y a des causes des pays du Sud que je suis parfaitement prêt à soutenir, en matière de développement, d'autonomisation, etc., etc.
D'accord.
Bref. Bon. Donc voilà, je démarre la conférence par une présentation des principaux arguments de ce bouquin.
Je me retrouve face à, donc, un libraire qui clairement a une petite claque habituelle, une dizaine de personnes. Et puis les premières questions, d'abord assez anodines, et puis de plus en plus,
biaisées, et puis finalement, des questions qui n'en sont plus dans le genre
D'accord.
« Mais monsieur Hénin, est-ce que vous pouvez quand même pas nier que
C'est ça.
Que c'est monsieur Fabius qui a armé les rebelles en Syrie et qui est à la cause de Daesh ?
» Et là je me dis : « Pom pom pom pom pom, mais c'est qui en fait les tarés que j'ai en face de moi ?
» Et là, je commence à faire ce que j'aurais dû faire en fait avant, c'est-à-dire à regarder les gens que j'ai en face de moi.
Mmh.
Et j'ai des gens qui ont des
Du poutinisme.
Des pins, des pins.
D'accord.
Des pins de la Russie impériale, des pins de je sais pas quel, de je sais plus quel parti communiste de la cinquième internationale.
Enfin, je sais plus quoi, enfin des trucs, mais complètement, complètement zarbi.
Mmh-mmh.
Et au final, je me rends compte que le rouge-brunisme, qui pour moi, jusque lors n'était pas un concept politiquement opérant. Parce que je trouvais que c'était juste
Fantaisiste.
Quelque chose de... une carpe du latin, enfin quelque chose qui existe, est en face de moi et est porté par une admiration pour Poutine.
Et je me rends compte que j'ai en face de moi cette espèce de syncrétisme, de « oui, on est anti-système, donc on est prêt à être Poutino je sais pas quoi ».
Et en fait, j'ai d'authentiques défenseurs de cette drôle d'idéologie qu'est le poutinisme en France.
Ok. Vous êtes face à ça.
Et face à ça, je me dis : il y a un truc. Et il y a un truc à creuser. Et il y a un vrai sujet.
Et donc c'est intéressant puisque vous quittez le journalisme et puis finalement, ce livre, c'est— vous y retournez.
Bah, c'est pas— oui, alors là, c'est mon livre le plus d'investigation. Donc, oui, de fait, c'est un livre de journaliste ou qui relève du journalisme, mais après, j'ai rapidement arrêté.
C'est ça. C'était vos adieux à la profession.
Un petit peu. Enfin, mais après, ça, je sais pas, peut-être, 'fin, il faut jamais injurier l'avenir, mais c'était une forme d'adieu.
Et donc c'est par ce biais que je me retrouve me dire : qui sont ces gens
? Qui sont ces gens qui se mélangent entre personnes qui ont des marqueurs d'extrême droite et des marqueurs d'extrême gauche
et qui sont réunis par une envie de perturber le système, mais pas perturber le système dans une optique émancipatrice, dans une optique, youpi, vive la liberté, soutenons les plus faibles, etc, etc.
Mais dans une optique, le système est mauvais parce que, parce que, parce qu'il y a des puissants qui nous gouvernent, enfin, ce genre de— 'fin, très vite, très vite rentrant dans des récits conspirationnistes.
Exactement.
Et au final, pour juste
juste se mettre au service du plus grand des criminels. J'aime pas les points Godwin et il faut éviter les points Godwin,
mais Vladimir Poutine est tout de même, et je pense qu'il faut, voilà, poser les choses telles qu'elles sont, poser des expressions.
Vladimir Poutine est quand même l'une des grandes incarnations du mal dans le monde aujourd'hui.
Ok.
Et du crime.
Il faut, il faut oser le dire, en effet.
C'est, c'est vraiment fasc-, c'est, c'est, c'est vra-, c'est vraiment fascinant, la, la figure de, la, la, la figure de Poutine.
Parce que Poutine est un syncrétisme d'autoritarisme. Il est à la fois l'héritier des tsars et l'héritier de l'URSS.
Il récupère des parties d'héritage sans tout prendre. Après, je suis surtout pas un spécialiste de la Russie.
Et ça, c'est une position que j'assume par rapport à d'autres personnes qui ont travaillé sur les réseaux du Kremlin en France.
Je pense en particulier à Cécile Vaissié, qui est tout de même une vraie criminologue, mais pure jus, héritière
Amoureuse de la Russie, oui.
Exactement, qui connaît, euh, qui connaît à la f-, qui connaît parfaitement et la langue et la civilisation russe et vient placer son analyse des créneaux dans ce,
de la criminologie, de la soviétologie, de la russologie française ou francophone,
puisque beaucoup de vos auditeurs ne sont pas français.
Mais moi, j'assume mon point de vue. Ma perspective est une perspective d'expert de la communication, d'expert de l'influence
qui cherche à analyser la constitution de réseaux, la circulation de récits et qui assume de n'avoir qu'une, somme toute qu'une connaissance superficielle
de la Russie.
C'est pas par désintérêt, c'est juste parce que ce n'est pas mon sujet. Mon sujet, c'est
c'est davantage les relations internationales, le droit international, le droit de la guerre, que j'ai eu l'occasion de fréquenter, de par, 'fin, ma présence, la couverture de théâtre de conflits.
Mmm-hmm.
Et en l'occurrence, par rapport à beaucoup d'autres journalistes de guerre qui ont beaucoup accompagné des troupes durant leur déploiement,
moi, j'ai énormément, au final, passé du temps aux côtés des civils dans les conflits que j'ai pu couvrir, parfois civils en armes, que ce soit des révolutionnaires, des insurgés, parfois aussi des terroristes, mais pas seulement.
J'ai fréquenté toute la gamme de ce qu'un conflit peut comporter de civils. Et cette perspective m'a donné une analyse des conflits qui est orientée sur les civils.
Et en l'occurrence, une conviction qu'on ne gagne pas une guerre sans prendre soin des civils. On ne peut pas.
C'est fascinant. Mais donc, vous arrivez donc avec un bagage de spécialiste, donc vis-à-vis de
ce que j'appellerais, oui, une forme de communication de la part de groupes comme Daesh et tout un bagage que vous avez présenté,
tout en étant finalement un peu néophyte vis-à-vis des questions qui concernent la Russie.
Et donc, ça vous donne une perspective intéressante et en même temps, à laquelle, de laquelle on peut se rapprocher en tant que lecteur, puisque nous ne sommes pas non plus spécialistes des questions liées au Kremlin.
Donc ça donne une perspective, je dirais, assez accessible et tout en étant profonde à votre livre. Donc voilà,
les questions que vous avez abordées sont celles, effectivement, qu'on va avoir le temps d'approfondir ensemble pendant ces trente minutes.
Vis-à-vis de la Russie, ce que disait Karl Marx en 1857, c'est que la Russie offre, pour le citer : « La Russie offre dans l'histoire l'exemple unique d'un immense empire qui,
même après des réalisations à l'échelle mondiale, ne cesse d'être considéré comme affaire de croyance et non de faits.
» Donc cette idée que c'est largement de la com en fait, la Russie, pour traduire Karl Marx
de nos jours. Donc on sait que la Russie a une économie plutôt médiocre, quarante ans de retard sur l'Europe selon le président de la Cour des comptes russe, une démocratie, on peut le dire,
largement fictive et une armée qui est loin d'impressionnante comme on l'a vu ces derniers mois en Ukraine.
Or, on a eu l'occasion d'entendre de plus en plus, y compris dans la librairie où vous avez eu l'honneur de présenter votre livre, de plus en plus, voilà, des louanges au sujet de la Russie.
On l'entend aussi sur Fox News, on l'entend aussi sur CNews, et des louanges au sujet de la Russie, de comment il fait bon d'y vivre.
Alors, est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de ce décalage, de cette capacité assez unique de la Russie d'être un empire objet de foi et pas de faits ?
Alors, je pense qu'il faut vraiment différencier la Russie du poutinisme.
Très important, oui.
Parce que la Russie, de facto, oui, n'est pas très attractive, elle est économiquement en retard, elle est d'un point de vue gouvernance, et cetera, elle est— démographiquement surtout, c'est une catastrophe.
C'est un pays qui ne cesse de perdre des habitants et qui continue, enfin, et dont la baisse démographique a été, qui avait été, qui était structurelle, qui a été accélérée par la crise pandémique,
encore accélérée par la guerre en Ukraine et par deux biais, puisqu'il y a d'une part, ben les pertes militaires,
qui constituent des morts hein, et d'autre part, les fuites de conscription qui restent des Russes vivants, mais qui ont fui le pays.
Ça plus une paranoïa vis-à-vis de l'immigration, enfin une position très hostile à l'immigration qui fait que c'est un pays qui ne cesse de se vider.
Bref, donc on a un vrai décalage. C'est la Russie poutinienne et l'idéologie poutinienne qui se présentent comme une alternative et qui réussit à gagner une certaine attractivité.
Et ça, c'est toujours mon angle d'attaque lorsque j'aborde les acteurs malfaisants. J'aime bien aussi étudier qu'est-ce qui fait l'attractivité du poutinisme, pourquoi le poutinisme peut attirer, quand bien même je suis un fervent opposant
de cette idéologie et convaincu que cette idéologie est
l'une des plus criminelles de notre époque hein.
Ben dites-nous.
Ce qui fait... En fait, Poutine, depuis une vingtaine d'années, a été relativement efficace. Lorsque vous voulez propager une idée, il faut être efficace en marketing.
Il faut réussir à proposer le bon produit à chaque personne,
répondre à chaque besoin. Donc, et ça, c'est quelque chose vraiment pour lequel
les idéologues poutiniens ont été efficaces : réussir à caser un produit qui vienne plaire à l'altermondialiste de Nuit debout, si vous vous souvenez de ce mouvement qui avait secoué
les places européennes il y a quelques années, comme une nouvelle façon de penser, la décroissance, l'altermondialisme, que sais-je,
comme l'officier supérieur catholique traditionaliste qui va trouver une réponse
aux questions identitaires qu'il se pose.
Un récit qui va réussir à convaincre aussi bien l'agriculteur français que, ben l'intellectuel ouest-africain, qui est persuadé que l'Europe n'a fait que du mal à travers
la colonisation ou l'anti-américaniste de je ne sais pas quel pays.
Bref, il y a une segmentation des discours qui est très efficace, notamment parce qu'elle n'a aucune crainte des contradictions internes.
Mh.
Lorsque Russia Today couvrait une manifestation, typiquement une manifestation gilet jaune, le message était la violence.
Mais de toute façon, c'est vraiment un principe avec Poutine, la violence est le message. C'est— à partir du moment où on a cette phrase en tête, on a à peu près compris le poutinisme.
Une fois que l'on met en ligne les images d'affrontement entre manifestants gilets jaunes et forces de l'ordre dans les rues, dans les beaux quartiers de Paris, on a une arme sémantique parce qu'on a arsenalisé un événement.
La vidéo va aussi bien fonctionner pour tous ceux qui n'aiment pas la police, principalement à la gauche de la gauche,
comme fonctionner pour, ben tous les milieux très pro forces de l'ordre, notamment à la droite de la droite.
Et résultat, les personnes qui, les gilets jaunes zemmouriens, au hasard
Mmm-hmm.
N'y verront aucune contradiction.
C'est ça.
Parce que, ah là là, ces enfoirés qui tapent sur les flics, mais quand même, mais quand même, en fait, c'est juste ah cet enfoiré de Macron qui envoie les flics écraser le peuple.
Donc au final, on s'en fout des contradictions.
Au final, on a un régime politique en France qui n'est plus complètement une démocratie et on vient totalement brouiller les perceptions, brouiller la compréhension politique des choses.
Et si la France n'est plus une démocratie, mais arrêtez de taper sur la Russie. La France ne vaut pas mieux.
C'est ça. Donc il y a vraiment dans cette stratégie via Russia Today, via Sputnik, via d'autres channels dont on parlera plus tard, l'idée de créer le conflit, créer la contradiction, brouiller le message et
Le confusionnisme. Le confusionnisme qui permet que plus personne ne ressente les contradictions et qui permette de, au final, ben pas mal dépolitiser les trucs, etc.
De provoquer un relativisme complet, une sorte de relativisme absolu qui est au profit des régimes autoritaires.
Puisque les régimes— ce relativisme, ce confusionnisme permet aux régimes autoritaires de dire : « Certes, nous ne sommes pas parfaits, mais vos systèmes politiques ne le sont pas non plus.
Par contre, nous offrons un discours révolutionnaire qui peut, et des plateformes et des outils
de propagation d'une forme de subversion au final, qui vous permet de vous libérer et qui en fait n'est qu'une drogue pour esclave. »
Mmm-hmm. Oui, il y a vraiment cette capacité, particulièrement en Russie. Vous dites les régimes autoritaires, moi, je pense que la Russie le fait particulièrement bien ou le Kremlin, devrais-je dire, de transfor-, de
Les auditeurs comprendront que ce qu'on désigne par Russie n'est pas la Russie en tant que pays, mais désigne la Russie poutinienne.
C'est un raccourci pour la Russie poutinienne.
Tout à fait. Mais c'est très bien de le préciser puisque effectivement, je pense qu'on risque de faire le raccourci plusieurs fois.
Mais donc, il y a un phénomène que j'appellerais de construction de réalité, où, voilà, qui participe à cette confusion et qui participe aussi à ce que,
ce dont vous avez été témoin dans votre librairie, c'est-à-dire un culte de la figure poutinienne, un culte de la Russie poutinienne.
Et ça, vous dites les régimes autoritaires, mais j'ai quand même l'impression que la Russie est championne dans ce domaine.
Est-ce que c'est juste dire ça ?
Oui, mais elle n'a pas l'exclusivité.
D'accord.
Elle n'a pas l'exclusivité. Orban, d'une certaine façon, fait pareil. Trump ne fait pas mieux. La Chine marche dans ses pas.
Enfin, l'illibéralisme est quand même un courant politique qui a méchamment le vent en poupe et qui est multiformat.
Oui, oui, oui. Alors on-
Et qui, encore une fois, ne s'embarrasse pas de ses contradictions.
C'est ça.
L'illibéralisme, c'est ce qui va permettre-- enfin, parmi les contradictions, on va avoir typiquement les personnes qui sont les mieux installées au monde, le milliardaire Trump qui se prétend anti-système.
Bien sûr.
Le président des États-Unis,
milliardaire lui-même, se présente comme un anti-système. Mais je veux dire, s'il n'y a pas un what the fuck, excusez mon français, qui est plus justifié que celui-ci, enfin, qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer ?
Oui, ou Zemmour qui crache sur la presse, etc. Enfin, il y a des-
Etc. Exactement.
On va continuer donc à explorer toutes ces questions de désinformation, des alliés de Poutine en France et en Europe.
On va continuer à aborder ça, mais juste avant ça, un peu de remise en contexte vis-à-vis de l'actualité de ces derniers mois.
Je pense que beaucoup en Occident ont été stupéfaits de l'assaut russe en Ukraine, puisqu'on ne suit pas forcément les évolutions de ces dernières années.
J'aimerais qu'on revienne là-dessus l'espace d'un instant, puisque je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à en dire, y compris en termes de construction de réalité, puisqu'on a pu entendre régulièrement des histoires comme quoi
Kiev était aux mains des nazis, qu'il y avait des crucifixions qui avaient lieu, etc.
Alors, je vais vous poser la question simplement : qu'est-ce qui motive Vladimir Poutine à vouloir prendre l'Ukraine de force ?
Quelle est sa direction première ?
Je vais faire une très bonne réponse de politicien qui ne répond pas directement, mais je vous déteste.
J'ai hâte, j'ai hâte, j'ai hâte.
Le drame, c'est que Poutine a gagné toutes ses guerres depuis vingt-deux ans. Il ne les a pas gagnées grâce à son armée, il les a gagnées grâce à nous.
C'est une honte. Depuis vingt-deux ans, depuis la Tchétchénie, la Géorgie, l'Ukraine première saison, la Syrie, l'Ukraine deuxième saison.
Parce qu'il faut-- parler de la guerre en Ukraine est presque un propre de, puisque la guerre en Ukraine, elle a commencé il y a huit ans.
Elle a commencé avec la saisie de l'Est et de la Crimée.
Du Donbass, oui.
Poutine est dans une logique de destruction. Et c'est ça la grosse différence entre l'URSS, le communisme soviétique et le poutinisme.
Le communisme soviétique était, inutile de le rappeler, criminel. A été à l'origine de déportation, d'emprisonnement, de massacre, de millions de morts.
Tout cela a été documenté, n'y revenons pas.
Le poutinisme est destructeur. L'objectif du poutinisme, c'est de détruire l'humanité,
de détruire le droit international humanitaire, de détruire les valeurs, de détruire tous les instruments qui régulent la politique dans le monde par des politiques systématiques de faits accomplis.
Et cela passe par des opérations militaires depuis la Tchétchénie. L'idée, c'est « je massacre pour exister, je massacre pour », presque envie de dire déréguler,
pour utiliser presque à mauvais escient un terme populaire.
En fait, quand vous présentez les choses en disant que son objectif numéro un, c'est de détruire l'humanité, ça évoque presque un méchant de film ou quelque chose de très, très manichéen, finalement, le grand méchant.
Est-ce que-- on a presque du mal à imaginer que ça puisse être aussi simpliste, entre guillemets. Il y a vraiment pas plus de logique constructive, une logique politique derrière, c'est vraiment-
La seule construction que souhaite Poutine, c'est la construction d'une alliance internationale de like-minded, d'affinitaires, de personnes qui-- avec le Xi surtout, avec la Chine, sur les...
Donc de personnes qui ne croient plus dans le droit, dans la justice. Ce que Poutine veut installer à l'échelle micro comme à l'échelle macro, c'est le droit du plus fort.
C'est tu me fais chier, je t'écrase. Excusez encore une fois mon langage fleuri.
Ça a le mérite d'être clair.
Mais ça a le mérite d'être clair. C'est tu m'importunes, tu me nuis, tu mets un-- enfin voilà, je t'écrase.
Une logique viriliste, finalement.
C'est de la brutalité.
Ouais.
C'est la brutalité à l'état pur et brutalité est sans doute un terme presque trop faible pour désigner du crime.
Mh. Et qu'est-ce qui explique le fait qu'il se refuse à reculer finalement puisqu'il est en train de perdre son conflit en Ukraine et
tous les observateurs indiquent qu'il ne va jamais abandonner, même en massacrant tous les conscrits qu'il peut trouver.
Qu'est-ce qui explique ça chez lui ?
Les conscrits, quand on regarde, ils sont de chez lui.
Mh.
Mais c'est-- il y a une logique potentiellement d'épuration. C'est,
quand Prigojine, le patron de Wagner, va recruter dans les prisons les conscrits, ben d'une certaine façon, potentiellement, ça l'arrange, ça vide ses prisons.
Oui, oui.
On est vraiment dans une logique de, je veux créer un pays neuf, je veux purifier par le crime et purifier par la destruction.
C'est une logique qui est d'un cynisme totalitaire sans nom.
Oui. Et-
Mais cela dit, je voudrais tout de même prendre la--
le point de vue russe et,
et me questionne énormément. Encore une fois, je parle avec beaucoup de prudence parce que je ne prétends surtout pas être spécialiste,
donc je ne vous fais part que de mes questionnements et de constatations relativement superficielles.
Mais il faut voir que Poutine est en train de détruire profondément son pays.
Par le-- depuis sa gestion de la crise sanitaire jusqu'à cette dernière guerre qui le met à genoux économiquement et achève son déclassement démographique.
On a aussi une destruction morale et mentale de la Russie, qu'il ne faut pas négliger, et qu'il-- parce que,
un vétéran demain de la guerre en Ukraine, un vétéran russe de la guerre en Ukraine, aura quelque chose de monstrueux.
Il aura tué, il aura violé, il aura pris part à des crimes. Et qu'est-ce que ça donnera comme citoyen pour la Russie de demain ?
On a vu, on commence à avoir des incidents violents entre Russes dans les centres de conscription.
Il faut avoir aussi de l'empathie pour, enfin voilà, une forme d'empathie, pourquoi pas, allez, pour les Russes qui demain se retrouveront avec des monstres en leur sein.
Mh.
Empathie ou pas, hein, c'est toute la problématique de la réconciliation.
Nous sommes d'une génération qui a vécu, qui avons vécu la réconciliation avec l'Allemagne et qui s'est basée sur la réconciliation avec l'Allemagne.
Parce que, pour plein de circonstances géopolitiques, dont la guerre froide qui l'a beaucoup facilitée, et puis aussi parce que l'Allemagne a fait un énorme travail à la chute du nazisme, a fait un travail colossal.
Les Allemands ont fait un travail colossal sur eux-mêmes. Il faut pas oublier, il faut pas faire une réconciliation, enfin se dire oui, la réconciliation belgo-franco-allemande était quelque chose de naturel et nécessaire.
Ça a pris du temps.
Elle est en fait, elle a été relativement rapide, elle s'est faite, elle n'a été possible que parce que les Allemands ont fait un travail monstrueux sur une prise de conscience de ce qu'a été le nazisme.
Et cette réconciliation n'a été possible que grâce à ce travail.
Il y avait eu-- il y a une activiste ukrainienne qui avait fait un peu un scandale, enfin qui avait provoqué l'émoi sur un plateau télé en disant : « Qui est l'ennemi ?
L'ennemi, ce sont les Russes ». C'est trop facile de dire qu'on est en guerre que contre Poutine. Nous, on est en guerre contre les Russes parce que les gens qui, les soldats qui,
qui viennent tuer et violer chez nous, ce ne sont pas des clones de Poutine, ce sont bien des Russes.
Mmm-hmm. Oui. Donc la réconciliation dépendra largement de ce qui remplacera, si Poutine tombe, de ce qui viendra après quoi.
Tout à fait. Il faut un changement de mentalité chez les Russes. Et de ce point de vue là, quand on parle de Russie, c'est pas forcément la Russie éternelle, mais c'est la Russie poutinienne.
Et la Russie restera poutinienne potentiellement après la fin de Poutine.
Time will tell.
On ne peut pas, voilà, juste se placer dans l'idée qu'il suffit, et encore, c'est une condition, que Poutine tombe pour arranger la situation. Non.
Vous faites bien de le dire, oui. Donc bon, on va revenir sur l'aspect communication, hein, puisque c'est plutôt ça votre spécialité.
Donc, vous parliez de une forme de brutalité, d'exterminer ses ennemis, etc.
L'image que Poutine aime beaucoup envoyer, c'est ces photos de lui très très musclé sur son cheval, qui prend la pose dans la nature, qui est sportif, qui fait du hockey, qui a-- voilà, tout ça.
Bref, et c'est ce qui souvent impressionne ses partisans à travers l'Occident. Une chose que vous dites dans votre livre, c'est : « Comme du temps du Komintern, Moscou achète ses soutiens ».
Alors dites-nous, qu'est-ce que c'est que le Komintern et pourquoi cette analogie ?
Alors, je vais revenir sur l'un des grands moments de mon livre qui est la rencontre Poutine-Sarkozy-
Oui
...au G8 de 2007.
C'est ça. La fameuse vidéo où on voit notamment un présentateur belge expliquer que tiens, Sarkozy n'a pas bu que de l'eau.
Exactement.
C'était monsieur Beauvert.
Dans mon bouquin, j'explique qu'il n'est pas ivre parce que aucun des deux ne boit, mais choqué.
Oui.
Choqué par un échange extrêmement musclé avec Poutine. C'était la première fois ou à peu près qu'ils se rencontrent après son élection.
Et Sarkozy se dit : « Bon ben, je vais poser les choses pour mener un dialogue franc et net, il faut que je pose les choses cash d'emblée.
Donc les sujets qui fâchent, je les pose sur la table et puis après, on pourra discuter entre adultes ».
Et ce qui n'a pas du tout plu à Poutine, qui le laisse parler et puis à la fin de la discussion, lui dit : « Bon ben c'est bon, là, tout fini.
Ben, je t'explique, ton pays, il est comme ça, le mien, il est comme ça. Et soit tu continues sur ce ton et je t'écrase ou sinon, voilà, c'est toi qui t'écrases, en gros, et on pourra continuer à discuter ».
Et c'est sous la violence de cet échange que Sarkozy se retrouve un petit peu sonné à prendre la parole-
On connait la suite aujourd'hui
...en salle de presse à ce G8. Ce qui est le plus intéressant, en fait, c'est-- parce que l'information a une histoire.
L'information, elle vit. Une fois que vous balancez l'information dans le domaine public, eh bien, elle est reçue par le public.
Et cette information avait un petit peu circulé après la parution de mon bouquin. Et puis, deux, trois ans plus tard, je me retrouve intervenir, raconter cette scène dans un documentaire qui passe à la télévision française.
Et le clip extrait de ce documentaire a fait de mémoire, mais des millions, si ce n'est une dizaine de millions de vues sur YouTube, enfin, en tout cas, a eu un parcours absolument incroyable.
Et ça m'arrive d'être arrêté dans la rue par : « Ah, c'est vous, le monsieur qui avez raconté l'histoire de Sarkozy et Poutine ».
Enfin bref, c'est l'un des, vraiment-- Mais ce qui est rigolo, c'est que donc cette révélation visait à illustrer la brutalité de l'exercice du pouvoir par Poutine.
Et dans un premier temps d'ailleurs, ce récit a circulé dans ce qu'on pourrait qualifier rapidement de cercle anti-Poutine pour illustrer, voilà, la brutalité de sa pratique.
Oui.
Sauf que très vite, il a arrêté de circuler dans ces cercles et très vite, on l'a retrouvé.
Et le plus gros de la circulation de ce clip vidéo, c'est pas tant sur la page web de Russie Libertés ou que sais-je, quelle page d'opposant,
mais je me suis retrouvé dans toutes les pages Facebook des pro-Poutine africains qui disent : « Le Poutine, c'est un sacré bonhomme.
Regardez comment il ose parler au colonisateur. Il a pas peur de Sarkozy, il a pas... » etc etc.
Ok, d'accord. Ça devenait une bonne chose, cette brutalité.
C'est devenu une excellente chose. Regardez le bonhomme, lui, il a pas peur de Sarkozy. Lui, il a pas peur du patron. C'est exactement ça.
Et donc j'ai été récupéré de facto par la propagande poutinienne.
Fascinant.
Et c'est cette seconde vie de cette séquence que je trouve presque plus intéressante encore-
Tout à fait
...que la séquence elle-même.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que, excusez le blackface que je me suis permis en prenant un petit peu l'accent africain pour illustrer cette récupération, mais même la brutalité est appréciée.
Et ce qui est cherché par les fans de Poutine, c'est la brutalité.
Oui. Et ces fans de Poutine ne sont pas, disons, des pions, ne sont pas en contact direct avec le Kremlin, mais il y a-
Non, ils ont un grand degré d'autonomie. C'est pas des gens qui sont traités par les services de renseignement russes, c'est pas des gens qui sont-
Il y a une faculté de la part du Kremlin à travailler en plusieurs couches, travailler avec leurs outils, leurs organes, leur Sputnik, RT, et cetera, pour ensuite générer des personnes qui, de bon gré, vont tout
consommer l'information et la recevoir sur un certain angle très très pro-Poutine et se dire : « Ben oui, ça répond exactement à mes frustrations » et-
Tout à fait. La diffusion du poutinisme est extrêmement low cost au final.
Mh. Ben parce qu'il arrive à trouver ce que les gens désirent en fait hein.
Mais c'est le principe du populisme.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Un populiste, c'est quelqu'un qui va voir quelqu'un qui est un petit peu remonté-
Ouais
...en lui disant, ou qui exprime une frustration ou des difficultés, en lui disant non pas : « Je vais t'aider à t'en sortir », mais : « Tu es en colère, tu as raison d'être en colère et d'ailleurs, je suis le chef de ceux qui sont en colère.
Rejoins-moi. » Indépendamment de tout, potentiellement de tout cadre idéologique ou-
C'est ça
...enfin voilà, c'est,
extrême gauche, extrême droite, extrême centre, à la limite, on s'en fout un peu. C'est--
T'as juste raison d'être en colère et d'ailleurs, je suis aussi en colère parce que t'as raison d'être en colère et surtout va-- enfin absolument pas orienté vers la moindre des solutions
parce que ça serait, ben, tuer le modèle économique hein, ce serait tuer la-- résoudre les problèmes des gens,
c'est tuer le rec-- le vivier des populistes.
Mh. C'est ça. Le Kremlin est passé maître en la matière, ça, c'est parfaitement évident. Et donc récupération de vos propos concernant donc la séquence Sarkozy-Poutine en 2008.
Et donc pour revenir à la question initiale que j'avais, c'était : Moscou achète ce soutien comme du temps du Komintern.
Qu'est-ce que c'est le Komintern et comment est-ce que Moscou s'en sort pour, entre guillemets, acheter ce soutien un peu partout en Occident ?
Alors, ça a changé depuis mon bouquin. Parce que justement, le Komintern, en fait, c'était la façon dont le Parti communiste d'Union soviétique finançait les partis communistes frères.
Mh.
Donc c'était bête et méchant, des valises de billets et un soutien strictement financier.
Ce qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui.
Ce qui n'est plus le cas parce qu'on est beaucoup plus dans la... enfin, le soutien qui est apporté, ça va davantage être d'ouvrir des plateformes alternatives d'expression.
On est plus dans de l'apport de moyens que de l'apport financier.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Un soutien à cette construction de réalité, un soutien
à ces... Voilà, on peut en parler maintenant en fait hein, les fameuses fermes à trolls de Saint-Pétersbourg, les ingérences dans les élections, ce genre de choses-là.
C'est à ça que vous faites référence, c'est ça qui a changé ?
Ça, c'est encore, c'était déjà 2014, 2017.
Mh.
Aujourd'hui, là récemment sur les midterms américaines, Prigojine affirme qu'il est intéressé d'en faire, mais en fait, j'y crois plus.
Je pense que la seule ingérence, c'est cette déclaration. Il est dans une logique de « je sème le trouble ». Il y a... je dis ce que je fais et je fais ce que je dis.
Lui, il dit pas ce qu'il fait et il dit ce qu'il fait pas.
Il fait pas ce qu'il dit, ouais, c'est ça.
Non, on est dans le pur confusionnisme et c'est le principe. Donc c'est...
Il y a un côté Tullus Detritus hein, pour faire la, ce qui est une grande référence en termes de relations internationales et de sciences politiques.
Enfin, cet album d'Astérix, La Zizanie, devrait être enseigné dans toutes les grandes écoles de décideurs. Et c'est clairement l'un des manuels du Kremlin.
Venir détruire le ciment des sociétés. Parce qu'à partir du moment où les sociétés sont divisées, à partir du moment où la cohésion sociale
est fragilisée, nous sommes moins forts pour prendre des positions fermes contre tel ou tel régime autoritaire.
Et ça, c'est vraiment la clé. Et ça nous offre aussi des pistes de réponse : la résilience sociale, le travail sur la cohésion sociale est clé.
Bien sûr que nous avons des divergences, bien sûr que la réponse n'est pas un tous derrière Macron ou tous derrière je sais pas quoi.
Non, évidemment non. En revanche, tous derrière nos valeurs. Nous avons dans nos pays qui sont des démocraties, nous avons au sein de l'Union européenne qui est l'une des meilleures productions de l'humanité de ces dernières décennies.
Oui, il faut l'affirmer, le réaffirmer. Bien sûr que c'est pas parfait. Bien sûr qu'on aimerait que ça fonctionne mieux, mais ça reste l'une des meilleures inventions, l'une des meilleures constructions de l'humanité de ces dernières décennies.
Nous avons derrière ces institutions, derrière ces valeurs, un bouclier contre des ingérences, contre des actions malfaisantes et nous savons pourquoi nous nous battons.
Et certes, nous avons des débats politiques qui sont légitimes et qui sont inhérents à la démocratie. Mais la polarisation induite par ces débats ne doit pas nous conduire à cesser de croire dans nos principes.
Ces débats sont inhérents à nos systèmes de fonctionnement. Ces débats ne veulent pas dire que nos systèmes, que nos institutions ne fonctionnent pas.
Au contraire, elles sont la preuve de leur salubrité. Et ça, c'est génial parce que c'est des sujets que je me retrouve retrouvé dans mes deux casquettes.
Mes deux casquettes qui sont lutte contre la radicalisation. Normalement, ben, je me retrouve régulièrement dans des
rencontrer des personnes radicalisées, y compris dans des établissements pénitentiaires ou des personnes à risque de radicalisation et qui me tiennent des discours en fait,
en fait, de défiance radicale vis-à-vis des institutions, évidemment.
Et puis, dans mes missions de conseil ou d'analyse de la désinformation où je me retrouve analyser les mécanismes qui produisent cette défiance radicale vis-à-vis de nos institutions.
C'est pour ça, par exemple, que pour moi, la pire réponse possible à une ferme à trolls, c'est une ferme à trolls qui vient dénigrer la ferme à trolls d'en face.
Non, on ne lutte contre la désinformation qu'en créant de la confiance. On ne lutte contre l'extrémisme qu'en créant de l'inclusion.
C'est pas en allant tenir des discours polarisés symétriques qu'on va venir annuler avec, ben j'ai un blanc, j'ai un noir et je veux tout...
Ça, c'est la logique de ces Américains qui sont très très très très forts pro free speech, liberté d'expression. C'est que le mauvais speech, entre guillemets, va être annulé par du good speech.
Et donc c'est d'ailleurs un peu la logique que met en avant ces dernières semaines un certain Elon Musk en rachetant Twitter.
C'est que Twitter va devenir vraiment free speech et que le good speech et le bad speech vont pouvoir s'annuler ou se démêler l'un de l'autre.
Et vous pointez ça du doigt en expliquant que non, c'est pas du tout ça la bonne réponse. C'est qu'il faut créer de la confiance avec du bon speech.
Et il faut de la modération, je pense aussi.
Il faut de la modération, il faut de la régulation.
Voilà.
Et il faut aussi de la... un de mes motto, un de mes slogans, c'est : freedom of speech is not freedom of reach.
Parfait. J'aime beaucoup.
La liberté de parole n'est pas la liberté de diffusion ou de... C'est oui, vous avez le droit d'avoir des discours extrémistes parce qu'en démocratie, il est permis d'être extrémiste.
Il est même permis de tenir des propos extrémistes. Et c'est le premier truc d'ailleurs que je dis à mes radicalisés.
Pour revenir donc sur la Russie et les ingérences et leurs contacts en France, ce que vous dites dans votre livre, c'est que ben Nicolas Sarkozy, François Fillon, Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen sont séduits par le poutinisme que
vous dénonciez il y a un instant.
Alors c'est intéressant parce que bon, François Fillon...
En tout cas, ils l'étaient au moment du bouquin. Après, tout le monde a... Le Pen, 'fin, pas mal ont, ils sont désormais...
Ils ont pris leurs distances, ouais.
Voilà, ils sont dans une logique où on efface les traces.
C'est ça. Juste, donc François Fillon, c'est assez clair puisque donc il a eu, hein, une position qui lui a été offerte, crassement payée, voilà, pour travailler avec le pouvoir russe.
Marine Le Pen, c'est aussi très très clair puisque son parti a été financé via un prêt de la part de la Russie.
Nicolas Sarkozy, je dois avouer être un peu plus surpris puisque vous donniez l'exemple d'une rencontre avec Vladimir Poutine qui était plutôt musclée et qui l'avait fortement intimidé.
Oui, mais justement, après il est devenu plus poutiniste.
D'accord.
Plus...
Comment est-ce que ça s'est concrétisé ?
Ben la vente des Mistral, la vente de ces deux bateaux qui a été heureusement in extremis annulée par François Hollande après l'invasion de la Crimée.
François Hollande qui n'a pas été
l'un des présidents français les plus courageux, mais qui sur ce point-là au moins a, voilà, nous a sorti d'un sacré mauvais pas puisque de fait, si les Mistral dans les années...
La livraison doit être faite, ou était faite, ça a été fait finalement à l'Égypte en quinze ou seize, quelque chose comme ça.
Si elle avait été faite à la Russie, enfin, je veux dire, ça aurait été désastreux pour la guerre actuelle.
En termes de capacité, les Russes auraient été, auraient eu un avantage très très significatif.
Et pourquoi est-ce que ça prend autant chez les Français, le poutinisme et la russophilie ? Qu'est-ce qui fait que les Français sont particulièrement réceptifs à...
Ça prend chez tout le monde. Ça prend chez tout le monde.
Oh parce que...
On a tout en fait chez Poutine.
Je me permettais de poser la question, non pas pour dire que la France avait l'exclusivité
du poutinisme et de la russophilie, mais simplement parce que dans votre livre,
vous expliquez que les Français ont, voilà, ce culte du chef,
cette crainte de la standardisation du monde qui revendique très souvent l'exception culturelle, un certain anti-anti-américanisme qui est très présent aussi, une nostalgie gaulliste.
Exactement.
Et que, voilà, et que donc il y a, disons, un terreau fertile. C'est pour ça que je vous ai fait venir.
Ouais, tout à fait. Je pense que c'est le... On a la façon dont gaullisme est récupéré. Mais là aussi, c'est un petit peu...
De la même façon que l'information, une fois qu'elle est mise sur le, enfin livrée au public, après, elle mène sa vie.
Un livre mène sa vie, une information, une œuvre artistique mène sa vie. Une fois qu'elle a été produite, eh ben le gaullisme, c'est un petit peu la même chose.
Une fois que de Gaulle est mort, eh ben il mène sa vie et tout le monde se retrouve à récupérer le gaullisme.
Ce qui est rigolo, c'est qu'énormément des poutinistes français d'extrême droite le récupèrent et se prévalent du gaullisme.
Mais on a aussi une vision, une lecture gaulliste qu'on trouve assez généreusement à gauche avec des gaullistes de gauche ou je sais pas quoi.
Mh. Oui. Et donc pour revenir à la question donc de des différentes personnalités qui ont été ou qui sont toujours ou qui effacent leurs traces ou qui ont été séduits par le poutinisme, Emmanuel Macron, est-ce qu'il en fait partie ?
Est-ce qu'il est un adversaire ferme ou...
Alors, Macron, c'est un Janus à deux têtes. Macron, d'un certain point de vue, c'est le plus libéral des libéraux.
Mh.
L'idée, c'est venir apporter des techniques du privé à la gestion publique, à la gestion des affaires publiques. Donc c'est un grand promoteur de la libre pensée.
Enfin, il aime à se faire passer comme un grand émancipateur, etc, etc.
Il a été visé d'ailleurs par, personnellement visé, on se souvient des Macron Leaks, donc à l'avant-veille de l'élection, au moment où la période de silence électoral entrait en œuvre,
eh bien, cette énorme boule puante sous la forme d'un hack and leaks était balancée.
Donc il a été visé par Poutine. Il a eu quelques moments de vrai courage. Quand au fort de Brégançon, face à Poutine, il lui dit, alors qu'ils sont en conférence de presse commune
: « Pour moi, Russia Today, c'est un organe de propagande, c'est pas un média ».
Je trouve que, ben voilà, c'est un vrai courage que je lui reconnais et qui ne peut pas lui être retiré, qui, enfin clairement, il faut lui mettre à son crédit.
Il y a ce côté où, ben Macron, à certains égards, peut paraître comme le meilleur, l'un des leaders du monde et qui est notre meilleur ami contre le poutinisme.
Et puis, il faut aussi voir la... enfin, j'ai malheureusement aussi tendance à voir une vraie fascination de Macron pour l'autoritarisme,
qui est très troublante,
et pour le populisme,
qui s'illustre par les mamours qu'il s'est senti obligé d'exprimer à Donald Trump juste après son élection, en l'invitant, en faisant de lui son invité d'honneur son premier 14 juillet, donc juste après son élection.
Ça, c'est extrêmement perturbant. Puis aussi sa volonté de reset, sa volonté d'essayer de dire : « Au final, il faudra négocier ».
Mh.
Son expression horripilante du : « Il ne faut pas humilier la Russie ». C'est pas ça le sujet. Je disais tout à l'heure une phrase qui, à mon sens, est vraiment essentielle qui est : Poutine,
depuis vingt-deux ans, a gagné toutes ses guerres grâce à nous.
Parce que depuis vingt-deux ans, il n'a cessé de nous tester, de regarder jusqu'où peut-il pousser le bouchon trop loin.
Mh.
Jusqu'où peut-il commettre des crimes, peut-il commettre des infractions au droit international sans que nous réagissions ?
Ou alors réagissions par de simples, un simple train de sanctions qui finissent par être contournées, édulcorées, sur lesquelles on finit par revenir.
Et en fait, le meilleur allié de Poutine, la meilleure chose que nous pouvons faire et ce qu'il cherche le plus dans nos sociétés, c'est que se propage l'idée qu'il faudrait un reset ou de la compréhension.
Non. À la brutalité, on ne peut répondre que par la fermeté, surtout pas la brutalité.
Quelqu'un qui ne parle que le langage de la violence adorerait nous faire répondre par de la violence,
quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs, que ce soit sur la scène politique, locale, internationale, que sais-je, enfin, quel que soit le rapport humain.
À la brutalité, on ne peut répondre que par la fermeté. Il faut, de façon ferme et aussi unanime que possible, se tenir en disant : « Nous considérons que ces actions sont inacceptables du point de vue du droit
et nous sommes fermement déterminés à utiliser tous les instruments que le droit nous donne pour contrer ces actions. »
Et il a été ferme en condamnant, en fermant donc Russia Today France, mais...
Ah ça, c'était une... non, ça, c'était une mesure européenne hein.
Ah d'accord, OK.
Non, c'était ex...
Oui, non, vous faites bien de le dire. C'était pas de mesure stratégique.
C'était une mesure européenne, bon certes, à laquelle la France a contribué. Donc il faut pas non plus, voilà, faire un...
Mais voilà, il y a eu une réponse qui a eu enfin un certain sérieux après la récente reprise du conflit...
Mh.
Ou invasion. Mais malgré tout, on continue de voir, y compris chez Macron ou dans son environnement proche, des atermoiements sur le thème : « Oui, mais au final, toute guerre ne se termine que par la négociation ».
Une occupation ne se termine que par une libération.
Mh, mh, mh.
Donc éventuellement, on peut négocier sur tel ou tel, je sais pas quel point de détail, mais une occupation ne se termine que par une libération.
Et donc y a chez Emmanuel Macron une démarche qui se veut assez neutre, qui se veut promouvoir la négociation, les longs appels qu'il fait avec Vladimir Poutine régulièrement.
Qu'il faisait, qu'il ne fait plus désormais.
OK.
Non, il le fait plus, mais y a eu... même ce, il a produit un film qui a des allures de feuilleton Netflix, La Diplomatie...
Mh.
dans lequel ont été déclassifiés, j'ai envie de dire, un certain nombre des appels qu'il avait eus justement...
D'accord.
En relation avec la guerre en Ukraine. Et ça, je trouve ça extrêmement dangereux. Parce que c'est une rupture de confiance sous couvert de transparence diplomatique.
Mh.
En fait, il a créé un précédent et je m'attends à ce que l'on ait un documentaire russe qui sorte,
qui reprendrait des appels menés par, bah typiquement, Shoigu, le ministre russe de la Défense, a appelé récemment un certain nombre de ses homologues occidentaux pour les mettre en garde contre
contre... 'fin, c'est intoxiqué, contre une bombe sale ukrainienne.
Mh.
Ce qui est un mode opératoire typique des Russes, des Poutine sadistes hein...
Ouais.
Puisqu'en Russie, avant chaque attaque chimique, il y avait des rumeurs que le camp d'en face allait en faire une attaque chimique.
Donc, qui permettait ensuite de semer le trouble sur l'attribution de l'attaque. Bref.
C'est ça. C'est ça, ouais, ouais.
Et je ne serais pas étonné...
Je ne serais pas étonné non plus, ouais.
Qu'on voie demain un documentaire qui, entre guillemets, qui contiennent certains, 'fin, des...
Des communications là avec...
Des communications de...
Représentants français.
Certaines de ces communications, notamment celles entre Shoigu et Lecornu, son homologue français. Donc à mon sens, c'était une erreur de communication.
Il faut maintenir les usages diplomatiques.
Mh.
La diplomatie a aussi besoin de secret. Elle a aussi besoin de confidentialité, qui est aussi une des clés de la confiance.
La transparence absolue, qui est aussi l'une des choses qu'adore promouvoir ou prétend promouvoir la propagande russe, enfin poutinienne, eh bien,
ne doit pas se faire au détriment de certains cercles de confiance.
Et ça, c'est un précédent qui est vraiment perturbant de la part d'Emmanuel Macron, que ce documentaire. Et qui-
OK.
Personnellement me gêne. Il faut rester dans les usages diplomatiques.
Alors, Nicolas Hénin, on va bientôt devoir se quitter. C'est intéressant parce que j'arrivais, je vous avoue, dans cet entretien en me disant qu'il y allait largement avoir l'idée que
la Russie recherchait, ouais, un rêve d'hégémonie, un rêve de ce fantasme, c'est-- comment est-ce qu'on dit ?
Eurasi- Eurasi-
Eurasiatique ?
Eurasiatique.
Ou eurasien, les deux.
Voilà, j'ai du mal à prononcer ce mot, mais eurasien. Hum, et donc un rêve de-
Je vous en tiens pas rigueur, c'est un mot très moche.
Oui. Y a ça. Y a un sentiment que vous évoquez dans votre livre hein, d'une certaine humiliation perpétuelle, de ce sentiment perpétuel d'humiliation chez les Russes.
Donc j'arrivais largement avec ces
idées-là en tête. Et finalement, ce que vous expliquez, c'est d'accord, il y a ça, mais il y a surtout un Vladimir Poutine qui veut détruire l'humanité, qui veut tout casser, qui est dans ce-
Mh.
Dans cette logique de conflit éternel. Donc comment est-ce qu'on réconcilie tout ça ? En fait, est-ce que c'est un peu le tout ou est-ce que-
Non, mais c'est le tout, c'est le tout. Et accessoirement, je me rends compte à vous réécouter, que
à vous réécouter me paraphraser que ce que j'ai développé à l'époque dans le livre sur ce sentiment d'humiliation qui a été énormément travaillé par la classe politique russe auprès de son opinion publique pour reconstruire-
Renforcer un patriotisme.
Reconstruire le patri-- renforcer le patriotisme et reconstruire une forme de cohésion nationale après la chute de l'URSS, qu'en fait, c'est l'une des principales ficelles de tous les populistes.
Ouais.
Que-
La victimisation, finalement.
Voilà, la victimisation, c'est aussi ce sur quoi bosse Trump sur sa fan base. Que de dire-
Voilà, les anti-woke adorent se victimiser en disant qu'ils ne peuvent plus rien dire, que c'était avant.
Exactement, exactement. Et Trump s'adresse à l'Américain blanc qui se sent humilié, humilié par je sais pas trop quoi d'ailleurs, mais qui se sent humilié.
Le retour des-
On est sur des grosses ficelles qui sont vraiment très, très simples. Sinon, un tout petit point.
On a fait le tour et qui éventuellement sera à remonter, mais je vous laisse la possi-- 'fin, je vous laisse, 'fin, c'est à vous de le mettre à bord de votre programme.
Dites-moi, dites-moi.
Mais on a fait le tour du, on a fait qu'un tour incomplet du paysage politique français, exclusivement en regardant la droite.
Quitte à ce qu'après vous reveniez dans le-
Absolument.
Pour le mettre pour finir le paysage politique français.
Bah on-- Je verrai au moment du montage. Mais effectivement, je pense que-
Voilà donc en fait-
On peut aussi parler de Jean-Luc Mélenchon plutôt, donc figure à gauche qui dirige aujourd'hui, gros-- voilà-
La principale coalition et la seule vraie opposition de gauche à Emmanuel Macron.
Et qui est intéressant puisque figure de gauche qui a tenté une forme de populisme au moment des élections.
Qui est en fait ultra Poutino-compatible. Et ce qui cause d'ailleurs au sein de la gauche française des tiraillements, des tiraillements, des tiraillements féroces.
En fait, ce qui est extrêmement triste, c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est dans le logiciel de, est toujours marqué,
en termes de relations internationales et dans une moindre mesure défense de Jean-Luc Mélenchon, a été formaté par deux individus qui ont tous les deux depuis quitté le parti.
Le premier, c'est Georges Kuzmanovic, qui a créé son propre parti qui s'appelle République souveraine et qui est à mon sens le vrai beau parti rouge-brun de France.
Et le second s'appelle Andréa Kotarac. Il est parti rendre visite à Bachar el-Assad en Syrie, dans une délégation guidée par Thierry Mariani, qui déjà faisait partie du RN, alors que lui était encore LFI, donc France insoumise.
Et à son retour de Syrie, il a déclaré son changement de cuti et son adhésion au Rassemblement national. Et la façon dont je vois le poutinisme, c'est un convertisseur de brun en-- de rouge en brun.
Et de ce point de vue là, quand on regarde les billets de blog que Mélenchon a écrits sur l'Ukraine, y compris cer- ou sur l'OTAN, y compris encore récemment, on les sent encore.
C'est quasiment comme s'ils avaient été écrits par Kuzmanovic. On sent que ces fils directeurs, son idéologie est encore profondément inspirée de ce que ces personnages, Kuzmanovic, Kotarac,
ont pu apporter au mélenchonisme et comment ils ont pu l'inspirer.
Et cette influence continue d'être parfaitement présente.
Alors la grande question, c'est puisque, voilà, s'annonce la disparition progressive de Jean-Luc Mélenchon du paysage politique français.
Bon, on l'annonce depuis un certain temps, il est toujours là, mais il finira par prendre un pas de côté puisqu'il continue à perdre les élections présidentielles à chaque fois.
Le jour où ça arrivera, est-ce que disparaîtront avec lui ses héritages Poutino-compatibles ?
J'en ai aucune idée. On a-
C'est-à-dire que est-ce que c'est le seul dans LFI à garder cette idéologie-là ?
On a au sein-- Non, on a au sein de la gauche française et plus on va vers la gauche de la gauche, plus c'est présent, une forme de tiraillement entre émancipation et anti-système, en gros, pour vraiment résumer en termes...
Mais je suis pas un très bon politologue, donc je parle vraiment avec beaucoup de prudence et du haut de une tour d'ivoire qui doit faire deux centimètres de haut.
Mais bref, enfin, et vraiment, j'essaye de garder... Je suis un obs-
Avec humilité.
Voilà une grande humilité parce que je me considère vraiment comme un observateur modeste et prudent de la vie politique française.
Mais je sens ces tiraillements. Il y en a d'autres, notamment sur les questions de la laïcité, évidemment, ou du communautarisme.
Enfin, tous ces trucs-là, c'est-- Je crois que vous avez fait d'autres émissions sur ces thèmes et vous avez-
Les marronniers en France, je connais un peu.
Donc voilà, on a un certain nombre de tiraillements au sein de la gauche française qui se recouvrent partiellement, mais pas entièrement.
Et, ben, j'ai envie de dire, c'est
les débats qui sont en cours qui vont conduire à de la recomposition, à ce qu'on ait,
eh bien, une adhésion de plus de personnes à une famille, à un groupe, un sous-groupe, une sous-famille, que sais-je, ou à une autre.
Et franchement, bien malin qui peut prédire à quoi ressemblera la gauche demain ou la droite d'ailleurs.
Je tombe souvent dans le piège de demander à mes invités de prédire le futur et à chaque fois, ils me répondent-
À chaque fois, ils se plantent.
Ce n'est pas possible. Non ! À chaque fois, ils me disent que ce n'est pas possible et que je ne peux pas poser ce genre de questions, ce qui est vrai.
Mais quel temps fera-t-il dans une heure ?
Et donc pour refaire le lien avec le sujet de ce podcast, cette-
Ce podcast n'a pas de sujet, c'est ça que vous avez pas compris. Moi, je parle de tout et il faut pas m'inviter sur un sujet.
Vous allez voir, je vais y arriver. Donc pour refaire le lien avec le sujet central, c'est que cette polarisation,
c'est le fait de pousser aux extrêmes comme à gauche comme à droite, finalement, bénéficie à la confusion dont on a parlé tout à l'heure et bénéficie donc indirectement
à Vladimir Poutine.
Est-ce que c'est ce qu'on peut dire ?
Ben ouais, très très indirectement.
Oui, écoutez, j'essaye, j'essaye de faire au mieux.
Non, mais de fait, de fait, à partir de-- globalement, à partir du moment où on se retrouve... Enfin, plus on se dirige vers les marges du spectre politique, moins on va avoir confiance dans les institutions.
Je pense qu'on peut à peu près le formuler comme ça sans trop se planter. Et le manque de confiance dans les institutions, ça oui, c'est un des gros objectifs du poutinisme. Voilà.
Mh. Voilà, formidable. Nicolas Hénin donc, un peu plus de septante minutes passées ensemble. Est-ce que vous voulez encore ajouter-
Non, mais il y aura moins de septante au montage. Non, je vous fais confiance pour faire seize minutes de danse hein.
Oui. Je couperai toutes les respirations et je mettrai tout en vitesse fois quatre et puis-
Voilà, voilà.
Voilà. Est-ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque chose avant que nous nous quittions ?
Pour ma défense ? Non, je pense que c'est-
Avant de se prononcer.
Non, je sais pas, on a fait le tour. Vous voulez rajouter quelque chose, vous ?
Bah moi, je suis très content. On a parlé effectivement d'énormément de choses. Donc si vous n'avez rien à ajouter, je vais me-- ah ben voilà ce qu'on peut rajouter.
Quelles sont vos actualités récentes ? Où est-ce qu'on peut vous retrouver ? Où est-ce qu'on peut vous lire ?
Ça dépend. Ça dépend, je--
Ça dépend des jours-
Ces derniers temps, j'ai-- ces derniers temps, enfin si, je contribue à quelques bouquins, mais j'ai pas de bouquins à moi.
Non, il y a rien de particulier.
Je vois un compte Twitter aussi sur lequel vous êtes-
J'ai un compte Twit-- j'ai un compte Twitter que je suis en train de virer. Donc voilà, c'est pas le bon moment pour me poser la question.
C'est pas le bon moment. D'accord, OK. Mais effectivement-
Éventuellement, éventuellement Mastodon-
Voilà, voilà. On enregistre cet épisode à une page tournante de l'histoire des réseaux sociaux puisque beaucoup de chercheurs, chercheuses, beaucoup de journalistes sont en train de quitter Twitter pour, voilà-
En tout cas de largement désinvestir.
C'est ça.
Est-ce que je vais garder mon compte Twitter juste pour faire du mass bashing ? Pourquoi pas ? C'est une hypothèse que j'exclus pas.
Pour faire la pub de votre compte Mastodon.
Ouais, ou rameuter, ou rameuter ailleurs, je sais pas. Je sais pas, j'ai pas de programme pour ce soir, pour tout vous dire.
OK. OK. Ben voilà. Mais je vous remercie alors en tout cas, puisque vous n'avez rien à promouvoir, je vous remercie pour votre-
Non, j'ai rien à promouvoir, ça, clairement.
Mais vous êtes venu ici alors juste pour le plaisir de discuter avec moi du poutinisme et je vous en remercie. On se retrouve alors dans deux semaines pour une interview d'une autre journaliste française et je vous dis à très bientôt.
Merci Nicolas, au revoir.
Merci à vous. Au revoir.
J'espère que ça vous a plu. J'ai mis tous les liens vers les différentes références en description. Le programme a été un petit peu chamboulé ces dernières semaines en termes de sortie de l'épisode de Septante Minutes Avec.
À l'heure où on parle, j'ai toujours pas sorti les teasers vidéo pour Laurence Minner ni pour cet épisode-ci. C'est compliqué hein, d'être podcasteur dans son temps libre.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que normalement, incessamment sous peu, le nouveau site de Septante Minutes Avec sera prêt. Ce sera sur septanteminutes.be en toutes lettres.
Ça fait quelques mois qu'on travaille dessus avec mon designer. Ça s'annonce très cool, vous verrez ça. Et donc dans une semaine, et non pas deux, comme je l'avais dit à la fin de mon, à la fin de l'interview,
je vais vous proposer une interview avec une podcasteuse française très célèbre.
Je vous garde la surprise. Et après, promis, promis, on retourne en Belgique. Bisous !